[Music]
808 drums a man was arrested after
exploded his victims Oh Chinese Chinese
girl I have so many questions was the
technique its how do they pronounce a
dim McAdoo mom yeah yeah
he basically breaks the bottom brick a
Japanese clan but then like they use the
Chinese word to describe their special
no no so basically Van Damme was taught
by this Japanese family his martial art
style and then if you really were like
taught from that family they have the
secret move called the Dutchman magic
but it's a real thing favorite line in
that movie this is when the kid who died
called [ __ ] jean-claude Van Damme
round I I thought that she was genius he
goes
I was a you see now you can do a lot of
things that came out in the 80s yeah if
you've seen that movie recently because
it's on Netflix the flashback it is so
it's half the movie yeah I didn't
realize that no one remembers it now me
going [ __ ] when do they cuz we were kids
you know who's in that [ __ ] Forrest
Wood
yeah he's the agent it's like his first
movie I've never seen it
they're like run around this guy act one
is like 45 minutes long because of the
flash man you know that's my cue like
holy [ __ ] this is so long but it's this
white guy with zero like with the French
accent I'm like how though for the US
military
yeah Frank Dux he's a real person like
yeah looked at and he's good he's a
fraud Oh is he a fraud he's a complete
fraud it's funny this videos about it
yeah kind of like Van Damme with this
[ __ ] French accent being an American
soldier yeah in the movie not there you
also play guile as a French man both
American the muscles from Brussels yeah
that's right let's figure out how we can
punch someone this took place in Alabama
this guy named Justin was 37 years old
has been charged with first-degree
assault because of what happened here is
he punched the victim hard enough to
make his eyeball pop out of his socket
and then the second punch exploded it
this this guy must see must be a boxer
he definitely has that see through it
one two no just so hard
there's this weird ocular condition that
certain people have where they could
pull their eye oh yeah I remember that
lady I saw just pop them out and I was
like Oh Guinness Book of World Records
whoever they had that TV show
like this was like 20 years yeah they
could do it and then they collected like
all the people who could push their
eyeballs out about that one and they
could see who could do it the furthest
ah God and they're sitting there and
they're like measuring it and I'm like
lovey like if I just was like you know
dude that guy I must he's gonna go down
to the zimos gangsters [ __ ] on
earth like I literally exploded
somebody's eyeball explode he punched
somebody like he [ __ ] up for sure oh
nine but it's not six nine
it's like sixty nine inches like
five-nine five-ten I like his look he's
like yep he's like I did that he's like
I [ __ ] up
that's a whoops face right yeah that
totally is like I just wanted to knock
him out but now I destroyed his vision
oh that is so crazy
why must have been a bar fight let's
fill in the blanks they were fighting
over Mountain Dew who's the last
mountain dudes calls publicist
no it's Alabama Mountain Dew sounds
right oh but they're not white though
what is it Shasta Cola
they were fighting over the last Shasta
Cola that's what happened so he was also
charged with driving they would hope to
license driving with a suspended license
failure to show vehicle registration and
driving without insurance oh these guys
are this guy's yeah he's nice he just
breaks all kinds of rules you know that
what did I told you I followed the one
worse I could fight this [ __ ] so good
fights I need I didn't look this up
there are certain ones that I really
enjoy but there's some that are so
brutal I can't watch it like that was
things alike I get excited because I
start thinking about what I would do in
that situation
run that's why we do but but where do
you run see I like it when the
girlfriend beats up the boyfriend okay
so there was a clip on Twitter of this
guy and his transgendered lover which
you don't know that they're in love at
the moment or they were together but the
guy that the transgendered person was
literally going into the dudes face
I'm his color so she was in the guy's
face yeah and basically he beat the
living [ __ ] out of her to the point
where he was her face was on the floor
he was stopping the back of her head
obviously assist pull of blood I was so
and this wasn't a pup obviously people
were just watching it go down and no one
no one steps in nobody stepped in I
wouldn't step in and so probably in film
it yeah I would film it no I wouldn't
apparently they were together it was
after the fact that there were a couple
or something and he beat the hell out of
her wouldn't you want to give evidence
to the police huh what don't you want to
give evidence to the police oh my god
you could just take your statement true
I don't know about like I saw this
person curb-stomped this other few know
publicly it's like one thing if there's
like one person there but obviously
there's a crowd of people that I
wouldn't use my phone not to record but
to call 9-1-1 yeah that was like a solid
I said there's like four or five people
there you can hear mine on man don't do
it man don't do it that's it and well it
was just basically like a lover's cruel
I guess it was like a lot of death did
that you survived I the person did
survive but you know smashed orbital
bone it was pretty bad yeah broken jaw I
saw another one it's a lot funnier too
clearly
okay to the brink of death there's a
there's a video of a police officer in a
New York subway and he's fighting
against eight bumps it's [ __ ] crazy
yeah so he's he's like stand backs he
has that like little he's like stab back
stab back right
and then these drunk bums keep charging
at him and he 300 kicks them and then
they knocked down it looks like a video
game video but people were actually
touting him to be like a well trained
officer yeah cuz he didn't decide to
just pull out his gun and shoot everyone
so like that's really think cuz he
really it's it is like eight against one
and he's like stay back
I'm gonna hurt you and he like pulls out
a taser and then he pulls a bugs from
the back that we're getting out of bed
just to fight this guy like cuz this
like I gotta watch Morris like a bunch
of white walkers that just rolled you
[Laughter]
he's like [ __ ] 300 kickin up there
falling in [ __ ] and then they're like
stumbling around cuz they're so drunk
and it one bump comes up and he's like
in the middle like stop yeah but there's
also other great things where I saw this
guy he was it was a video clip of a guy
watching a crackhead run in the middle
of street and he goes don't do a flip
[ __ ] does a [ __ ] flip it's crazy like
have you seen those memes about like the
Olympics gymnastics they're like ah
let's just let's just stop cuz you know
we always lose to China and Russia
anyway just forget about our gymnastics
team so let's just send a team of
crackheads when easy just wicked cuz
they'll do a quadruple backflip aerial
onto concrete with their teeth first and
stand up and do this leading with no
teeth still [ __ ] lizard and they walk
and they have the random [ __ ] koala
on their shoulders and their bald eagle
there was a guy in New York for a while
that all time heavy dreads but he had a
white rap that would sit on his shoulder
and like people would recognize him in
the neighborhood cuz he just it was like
it was his best [ __ ] it was a rat it
wasn't like a man you've seen one with
the skunk
they just mastered like all the trash
animals Oh like an armadillo he's just
like Beastmaster Beastmaster yeah with
that it was that it's like I wanna be he
man kind of guy yeah that's that's
Hercules I ah and then vena I love just
the princess warrior dude yeah I wish I
knew more about this victim that I got
his eyes oh my god guys I'd have a fight
contract by the time gets it for sure
like when when you get into a fight you
think it's just gonna be a fair and
square regular fight and then you do a
little bit more damaged and you intend
it and you're just like oh my god
I would never want again to a fight with
a stranger ever does you don't they bite
no but also like you never know if they
got AIDS what if they got yeah weapon
that's not worry you don't know what
that person those fights are never clean
I think people always to be like they
have the measles that's it dude this
whoa there's one during a high school I
remember my name was Julian but he got
into a fight at this gas station look
Enquirer really nice dude but he's like
a thug are you gonna make us sad again
well he socked somebody so [ __ ] hard
you could see the chunk that was missing
from his head from the guy's [ __ ]
tooth it was it's great but that like in
the movies who really wanted to fight
they're all intact well I don't know the
guys too but his he had like you could
tell us like a tooth that ripped the
charm on his [ __ ] hand yeah I mean
did that guy deserve to be punched I
don't know Julian was a mean guy so I
know my season choir oh you should've
just saying instead man I know blew up
his eardrums you got it you got it going
out the way
[Music]
[Music]